page should be based on productivity and
skills not just yeah I agree that's
that's a good that's a good story and I
think for the most part it is I think
women just don't want to do like the
most stressful jobs that are that are
worth more money and I can see it in my
company like I pay my recruiter double
what I pay my personal assistant my
personal assistant tried to be my
recruiter for a week he hated it she
hates she was like you could give me
double the money and I do not give a
like this job's horrible it is I'm
recruiting for pot oh my gosh you know
yeah that was the struggle and and it's
like women don't want to do stressful
jobs we would rather just like and women
I think are better at like more
organizational stuff so she's really
good at being like a personal assistant
um but unfortunately like one is more
valuable to me than the other